[Music]
um anyways jared leto morbius
yeah i don't know i just like love when
big budget movies get bad ratings i
don't know why it's isn't it like
satisfying yeah on rotten tomatoes 23 oh
let's go yeah yeah
you know well
did you oh you didn't seem at the
grammys did you no that [ __ ] got
out there like in this like shirtless
like sex chain mail
like he had like a suit jacket on and
then he had um literally a chandelier on
his body 16
yeah
audience seemed to like it but you know
is that [ __ ] i don't know
like uh uh here's another one i um
we went we were like gonna walk watch
judd abattow's new movie last night the
one on netflix yeah it's called bubble
yeah and i was like i'm just gonna check
the reviews real quick and i just
googled it and like the first headline
is
uh fans agree bubble is the worst judd
avatar movie that's ever been made sick
i know we watched the first like two
minutes i was like god even just even
just like [ __ ] just the concept of a
pandemic movie now
now at this point it's like dude it is
way too late yeah no
no i don't want to be reminded of this
[ __ ] anymore nah we're all it's done you
know i think what's also interesting
about that dude is
the timeline for people like with the
pandemic is like different depending on
where you go you know like in florida
that [ __ ] is so much older to them than
it is even to us yeah yeah yeah they've
been unrestricted for over a year yeah
so yeah imagine dropping a [ __ ]
pandemic movie there they'd be like what
are you talking about yeah yeah that's
that's what i mean like it's not yeah
it's obviously not done people are still
dying from it every day but it's just
like
like
art wise movie wise reference wise we
don't want to hear about it anymore yeah
i don't make jokes about quarantine
anymore that was like why would you want
to go back there yeah
well i think you could say it's
in a way it's done
yeah i mean yeah i guess like yeah
restrictions wise it is yeah that's what
i mean which makes it hard to think
about it mm-hmm yeah and the media
doesn't talk about it anymore no
no they've moved on
thank god for will man
yeah
you know
slap the cove ukraine coverage was
running dry they were like we need some
other violence yeah exactly like finally
let's go days extended yep
we got us something else
wait geraldo was so committed to playing
morbius that he would use crutches and
slowly limp to the bathroom
however the p breaks began taking so
long that it was slowing down filming so
a compromise was made for him to use a
wheelchair
wow that's hilarious yeah
uh yo dude we know your method and
everything but you're methodically
[ __ ] up the scale
so we're gonna have someone push you to
take the piss what's up with morbius is
he like handicapped
no he's like um
he's like a doctor
that i guess turns into
a beast
why why the crutches what was that oh
sorry yeah
maybe he is injured or something
as a doctor
i don't know
huh yeah
play the trailer it's
on the surface is a very confusing movie
okay yeah play the trailer
in a world
where people are ugly
you need a doctor
i am a doctor okay so i guess he can't
walk
i should have died years ago
oh he's got he's got like uh to have my
disease from here
to find a cure we have to push the
values take the risks
if you're gonna run
do it now
you've been missing for two months
you were discovered by pete davidson
[Music]
yeah yeah so he's like this super
powerful beast thing that like eats
people to like keep going so he has
i think morbius yeah she has the dilemma
up it's morbid
[Laughter]
he has the dilemma to continue to eat
or save yeah whatever and then in his
real life he saves people yeah something
like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] deep right yeah seriously
yeah
i always forget that he was in 30
seconds to mars
he's still in 30 seconds to mars is he
not yeah he is but they like introduced
him to that at the grammys they're like
it's like oh what doesn't he do he does
this and then it's like and you got to
show up naked
like yeah come on bro don't you have
enough attention
and and
if if there's anyone [ __ ] harvesting
fetuses and eating them for
youth it's that guy it's so funny now
hasn't he played like two cult leader
roles and he like has a cult basically
he has a call oh that's what
but he has a cult yes that's what like
the 30 seconds to mars fans are
no he has like a church
he has a legit call yeah
jesus christ i don't want to [ __ ]
read this it's going to creep me out
oh yeah no you should be creeped out
yeah it's like a dude who like has this
cult and has this band and like first of
all you know the average human if they
featured in a movie that bombed the box
office like that
and they're like you want to come host
the grammys
i think a normal human would go ah
i don't know man the review's been
pretty mean i think i'm gonna just
lay low for a minute right and he just
walked in there with the utmost
confidence he's like nah now i'm gonna
go there cause he's in like nine other
things right now yeah he is he's in the
wework show i guess he can't care yeah
he's 50
he's 50. oh yeah so he's eating like uh
heart he's harvesting baby forest that's
what i'm saying yeah
yeah
oh yeah he's drinking kid blood are you
joking
it's gonna come out like how he looked
like this for so long and it's gonna be
horrific
you know what's funny is that like i
think the box office
of open like the opening weekend of
morbius i think was like 80
85 million or something like that i
think the budget was 75 million was it
just so funny to make for the studio to
make 10 million bucks yeah they're like
yeah
like if they thought it was gonna be a
billion yeah
it's like 10 million yeah it's not a
flop but it's like you know that's
literally yeah they didn't lose money on
it but it's just like breaking nothing
compared to what they could have yeah
breaking even yeah
yeah well we we made a movie yeah we
made one we definitely made one more
obvious is out there yeah
you know if you're better for worse you
can and you can get a ticket for it you
can watch it yeah we made one please but
you got to love those yellows box office
deficits i was like oh that movie was
all right what was the budget
120 million holy [ __ ] how much they make
3 million
they're upside down 117 million that's
crazy that's [ __ ] [ __ ] up